russia meantime is intensifying its
battle for control of eastern ukraine
after claiming it had completed the
capture of the port city of mariupol on
the black sea ukrainian fighters have
surrendered at a still mill in the city
ending what had been a symbol of a
months-long resistance against the
russian invasion this morning president
biden signed a 40 billion dollar aid
package to help ukraine and its allies
ukrainian president zielinski wants
russia to pay for war damages and in a
related development this morning russia
cut off its supply of natural gas to
neighboring finland after finland said
it would join nato deborah patta reports
on some of the people caught in the
battle for ukraine near the country's
second largest city kharkiv
the village of kutizka has had a drive
first it was occupied then when russian
troops were pushed back it came under
relentless shelling as russia fought to
keep its much needed supply route to the
east open
this gloomy basement was home to 140
people when the war started
among them 40 children some families
managed to escape others were trapped
now the only kid left in this dystopian
hideout is eight-year-old timothy sudov
and the women depleted by war
nobody gets much sleep here
above a brutal battle was being fought
vladimir putin had set his sights on
capturing the city of hatkiev kuchuzevka
was in the way
this was the front line pedro told us
during the fighting our house was
shaking
just 15 miles from the russian border it
was only recently liberated
on the rare occasion villagers came
outside during the occupation they would
see soldiers but told us they didn't
speak to them
the russian troops may have been pushed
out but their rockets can still fly in
timothy is too traumatized to even talk
about it he must have been scared
all his friends have left the bunker he
misses them the most do you have a best
friend
where's your friend now oh
they ran away he says blankly
everyone here thought they were going to
die
we covered our ears said his mom and
curled up together
today volunteers brought food and water
and even a rubik's cube for the little
boy
it helps pass the time he gives me a
gift one of the first pictures he drew
with a cheerful sunny sky
the colors are beautiful
up late
it's only been monsters
and tanks
for 84 days timothy suffered
unimaginable horror his mom told us he
would scream during the shelling he
starts humming whenever she speaks about
the war and seems almost too frightened
to make eye contact for cbs saturday
morning deborah patter harkeef
heartbreaking absolutely heartbreaking
deborah thank you